where you place your attention is where
you place your energy
and all of your attention is in the
present moment
you've got a lot of energy to do amazing
things being present
is literally nothing more than the skill
of having your thoughts be in this
moment not in the past
not in the future but right here observe
where you are bring your full
senses to your next experiences want to
be happy
live a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because
you know you're capable of more you have
michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the seven ways to
become more mindful
and present enjoy
okay let's kick it off with way number
one pay attention with joe dispenza
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy
and all of your attention is in the
present moment
you've got a lot of energy to do amazing
things and you know when someone's
present with you in your life because
they're paying attention to you
and you know when they're not present
because they're not paying attention to
you so
so the act of getting more present means
you're putting a lot of energy in the
present
moment and you're taking your power back
from all these things and
people in your life so we teach people
this
as they start breaking through and they
start being able to unfold into this
field as an awareness
and they're not putting their attention
on their boss or their ex or their wife
or their kids or their cell phone or
their whatsapp or their facebook
they're they're they're they're not
thinking at all
so then as they're sensing the space
they can't think and if you can't think
you can't analyze and if you can't
analyze the analytical mind is what
separates the conscious mind from the
subconscious you just open the door
wow and so now you can reprogram in
there
right so then it's so important then
that of the
infinite places you can put your
attention let's put it on your heart
now where you place your attention is
where you place your energy why
because we want this center to bloom
fourteen hundred
thirteen hundred different chemicals
that we storm regenerate the body
let's breathe let's open this up let's
practice this let's
start learning how to lead with a heart
a different consciousness
yeah in the beginning it's a little
difficult but
you stay with it and you practice it
pedal by pedal by pedal
placing your attention there you're
putting your own life force
back into your heart you're turning your
love inward and the body will start
responding
and in a week's time if we're doing that
three times a day or
over and over again sooner or later that
thing's gonna start blooming and
just like when your sexual organs are
aroused and they're engorged with blood
this center when you start feeling love
you make a chemical called oxytocin
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide
signals a chemical called derived
endothelial relaxing factor you know
what that is
it causes the arteries in your heart to
literally
open up so your heart is going to be
filled with blood and
oxygen and nutrients it's physiological
it's going to feel
full you're going to have a heart on in
a sense
your heart is going to fail right and
when that happens
you experience a level of love
that passes all understanding you your
cup
runneth over way number two savor the
moment with mel robbins
being present is literally nothing more
than the skill
of having your thoughts be in this
moment not in the past
not in the future but right here the way
that you teach yourself how to do that
is that the moment that you catch
yourself
being distracted the moment you catch
yourself starting to worry
the moment you catch yourself drifting
to the future drifting to the past
that's a moment of tremendous power
because you basically just woke up
you basically just noticed that you're
not here in this particular moment
so use that wake up call 54321 and
ground yourself in this moment
the best way to ground yourself in the
moment is to look for something
in this particular moment that you can
savor now i'm using the word saver
on purpose because it's the word that
psychologists use to describe
what happens when you find something in
this moment right now
right here right now to focus on and to
appreciate
it could be literally the questions
these are these are printed out
questions from people on social media
and
if i were to stop and look at these and
savor them
what i would feel in this moment is a
tremendous amount of gratitude because
people are taking the time to write
and that makes me feel incredibly
grateful and it also makes me very
happy because it means that that the
folks that are writing
are taking control of their lives and
seeking out the information that they
need
another form of savoring that we can all
relate to is eating
as you're eating instead of drifting to
the future and thinking about all the
things that you need to do
or hanging out in the past and rehashing
everything that's happened during the
day
be in this moment in this meal slow down
think about the food that you're eating
think about the people that you're
sitting with and
how you feel about them and if you want
to take it up a notch
actually acknowledge them hey this food
tastes amazing thank you for cooking or
i'm so glad to see you and that we get
the time to have this meal together
those small simple acts of savoring are
how you
expand your happiness inside the present
moment
so how do you be more present simple
the moment that you catch yourself in
the future in the past worrying whatever
refocus yourself right here right now
and then find something
right here right now that you can savor
and when you do that you're not only
going to be present you're going to feel
more grateful
and you're going to feel a little boost
of happiness way number three beat
digital distraction with robin sharma an
addiction to distraction is the death of
your creative
production there is research coming out
now saying
that the average person checks their
phone 200 to 500 times
every single day as i share in my book
the 5am club
your phone is costing you your fortune
if you look at the great geniuses of the
world the shakespeares and the basquiats
and the beethovens
the great chefs and the great titans of
industry and the great humanitarians
all great thinkers have one thing in
common they
spent long periods of time
away from diversions distractions
trivial interruptions so
you can be like the majority being busy
being busy
or you can be a history maker and a
legendary producer
and not being on your phone not playing
with technology every second
not being addicted to that white screen
you don't get to do both
so if you really want to multiply your
creativity and if you really want to
accelerate
your productivity this episode of the
mastery sessions
will be incredibly valuable for you and
i'm going to get
right into the first habit that will
help you beat
digital distraction and that's build
your tight bubble of total focus
so there's a relatively new term coming
out right now called digital dementia
digital dementia we are spending so much
time in front of our screens
that we are waking up with this full
well of cognitive bandwidth in other
words our gifts and our glory
in terms of our brains capacity we wake
up and we're ready
to go and then what happens is in terms
of digital dementia
we check our phone we check our email we
check for likes we watch a video we play
with an app
and every single piece of attention
that we give to one of those
distractions
is stealing your cognitive bandwidth
this is really important you wake up
full of full of cognitive potential
full of the ability to be creative and
productive and
every single time you check up your
screen some of your
cognitive bandwidth that's the term that
the researchers
and neuroscientists use is left on the
screen
another term is called attention residue
you leave a residue of your attention on
the screen
and then you turn on the news more of
your attention
is left on the news and then you check
for email
more if that attention residue is left
on the email and then you'll find it's 8
o'clock or 9 o'clock in the morning
and you can't focus and your creativity
is depleted
well it's not because you can't bring on
your fire to
dominate your domain it's because you
haven't managed
yourself like the pros do way number
four
learn to observe with brendan burchard
here's
my big tips for you number one start
out learning to observe where you
are and what i mean by that is
you know mindfulness while we all think
it's a
meditative trick up here and we'll talk
about meditation it's great
but as much as we think of mindfulness
as the mind
i like to think about it too as the full
activation
of your senses in the moment
what that means is a lot of people
they'll walk into a restaurant they'll
see their friend they'll walk over their
friend they'll sit down they'll eat a
meal and everything but they never
actually looked around
the restaurant they never smelled the
smells in the restaurant
they never breathed the air in the
restaurant and sort of intentionally
and so they weren't really in the
environment or the situation
we've learned to block out distractions
so much so that we can focus
we've also learned to block out then
life
so observe where you are bring your full
senses
to your next experiences observation
of the setting the context
where am i right now what's the color of
the walls
what's it smell like here what's it feel
like here
what's this environment human beings we
do have a natural ability to pay
attention to our environment
i want you to activate that again
consciously
notice where you are and the more you do
that the more you'll start to feel
presence in life second
observe how you are
what i mean by that is observe how
you're interacting with the environment
observe how are you sitting right now
how are you breathing right now how do
you
feel right now observe
that more consistently to see
how am i being in this relationship
right now with this person
how am i speaking to them how do i
probably sound
to them observing self
in situations starts bringing a more
mindful mentality to us it also allows
us over the long term
to be more intentional because you know
what the more you observe yourself
the more you start seeing things you
don't like about yourself
gosh i don't like how i talk to her i
don't like
how i'm missing my children even being
in the room with me
because i'm not paying attention i don't
like how i feel continually
i'm always anxious and negative it all
comes and all all improvement from there
begins by observing it paying attention
to it
right so observe where you are observe
how you are and then specifically
observe
your impulsive thoughts those impulsive
thoughts that come up that i always call
you know the drama mind the first
immediate reactions
to things which in the modern world are
usually not the
most that was a best response right we
get all upset about something
take a beat distance yourself from
stimulus
and response step in that space in
between
and be intentional what do i want here
what would serve here how would my
highest self
respond here i would say my biggest
breakthrough in mindfulness came
as a 19 year old kid when i learned that
to ask
how would my better self respond to this
situation
versus being a child all the time being
so upset all right my friend
evan carmichael's book listen humans are
built to serve
some people are built to serve the world
others
want to serve the 25 people closest to
them but in either case humans are built
to serve so if you're not happy right
now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
way number five regain your focus with
oprah winfrey
i found myself at the beginning of this
pandemic
feeling several things first uh when
lockdown came
i was excited because whoa i thought it
was only going to be
like two weeks and i was treating it
like
vacation and i didn't have to fit into
any pants
so i was eating everything i was like
counting the points in my head but not
really tracking them and then when i
realized we're going to be longer i
thought
after i put on the first seven pounds i
said whoa
let's get ourselves refocused and back
on track i was feeling overwhelmed
well but i will tell you that for me
being the practice of of
being fully present has saved me and one
of the reasons i was feeling overwhelmed
and eating my way through the first two
weeks is because
i had just come off of that tour and i
saw many of you i see some faces that i
saw
on the tour hey lisa i see you there um
i um uh and i realized
you know as more and more information
was coming forward that
wow i after every show y'all
shook had 400 500 people
waiting in line to take pictures and
shaking hands so i shook hands
i hugged people people kissed me i
kissed them we cried we danced we did
everything and then i thought
14 for the first 14 days
after the tour finished every day i was
waiting to
like know whether or not i was going to
be
a victim of covet 19. i
am in the at risk risk category i am 66
never before have i been reminded of
that number because at first when
the news started coming out about uh it
affecting elderly people i was like oh
so sad the elderly people then i
realized they were talking about people
over 60. oh they're talking about me
oh i didn't realize i was elderly
okay thank you so much and as i've
shared with so many of you i had
pneumonia last year so
i'm really in that category of ad risk
um so i was worried
and if you're watching the news every
day as i know we all have been
needed for information i have now
stopped and limited that for myself
if you're watching the news every day
you can get overwhelmed with the stories
and i was reading every terrible
horrible story
of what it does to your body and how it
shuts down your lungs and then it makes
your heart race and then your kidneys
fail and
all of that okay do i have a witness
over there i see you linda
and so i had to stop i had to stop doing
that i had to stop doing that
and every time i would i would get
overwhelmed i would do this i would just
literally
go to my breath and remind myself that
breath is the presence of life it
reminds you that the breath is literally
the source
of life for you come back to focus and i
would say
in this moment i am well in this moment
i'm okay i am not in the hospital i am
not
on a respirator i am not that story in
this moment
i am breathing i am well i'm okay coming
back to the moment coming back to the
moment
reminding myself in this moment i am
well
way number six do things consciously
with gabrielle bernstein
i've been in a whirlwind as you can
imagine with the launch of my newest
book the universe has your back
i've been visiting cities all over the
country going to other countries
and really trying to keep up with all
that is around me and all that has been
created
and while it's extremely exciting to
create and it's extremely wonderful to
be busy
we have to have tools for slowing down
and i believe that the key to slowing
down begins with your conscious
choice to go more slowly your decision
to be more simple your decision to be
more graceful your decision to be at
ease
and this is something that doesn't come
very naturally to me i was born two
weeks early
i like to be on time and make things
happen fast
and i've lived in a way for many many
years where that fast-paced
attitude got me pretty far but i'm
beginning to notice that if i don't
learn
to proactively slow down i won't be able
to sustain all that is around me
so being fast and moving fast has its
benefits
when you need it but it's not
sustainable
that fast-paced energy blocks our
connection to the universe
it blocks our feeling of receptivity it
blocks connections
and so we have to be conscious of
knowing when to speed up
but having conscious choices every day
to slow down and so the first step as i
mentioned
is to choose to go more slowly
choose to eat more slowly choose to walk
more slowly choose to read more slowly
choose to breathe more slowly and this
conscious choice
is is a habit that must be created and
some of you may be out there being like
hey i go so slow and that's my thing
i'm speaking for myself right now that
fast-paced vibe
is not necessarily the way to be
sustainable in my life so you know where
you are on the spectrum of
fast versus slow but if you feel like
you've been
moving too quickly controlling trying to
be
everywhere at one time taking on too
much then this prac this process of
choosing to slow down will greatly
benefit you
so step one choose it really consciously
make that decision
then at least three times throughout the
day and this is i like to use the choice
of three because
it's manageable it's doable but it's
enough to create a new pattern
three times throughout the day for maybe
a month maybe longer
be conscious to check in about your
speed
so i try to do it while i'm eating i
have three meals a day so when i'm
eating
i sit down and i try to be conscious of
how fast i'm going
how fast are my thoughts how fast is my
breath how fast am i eating how fast am
i chewing
and starting to just be in the presence
of the speed with which i'm living
and you may choose other areas of your
life where you move too fast maybe you
move too fast while you're trying to get
from place to place or you move too fast
when you're sending emails
but choose three conscious places
throughout your life where you can tune
in
and just check yourself check how fast
am i moving
and can i consciously slow down the
process of slowing down will come
naturally as you begin to witness
the speed that you are moving and so
that witnessing process really is all
that we need
the desire to slow down and the
witnessing of the speed
is all that we need to begin to change
the pattern when you see yourself in
that pattern remember it's never too
late to slow down
you could be 90 through that meal and
you could chew the last 10 percent
and that is perfection so learning how
to slow down
at the best of your ability at a pace
that is
reasonable for you and really just
trying three times a day
and i like this concept of just hitting
those marks three times a day
seeing if i can just bring myself back
the simplest way to come back as well is
through your breath
so just taking a deep long breath
to bring yourself back to center feel
like you're slowing down your energy
and reorganizing your nervous system so
that you can continue on with your day
with grace and with ease i'm on my own
path with this it's not easy
but it is definitely serving me greatly
to stay committed to this practice
and way number seven the last one before
very special bonus clip
is meditate with deepak chopra what's
something that people can do daily to
access that
experience because like you said our
days are just busy with work and family
and commitments and events
what's something people can do daily
that helps them access their
true identity their self going beyond
the ego and the mind and the body
i think the basic of it is to still the
mind
as much as possible and
just become a silent witness
um to that which is happening on the
screen of your consciousness
so if you um close your eyes and take a
few deep breaths
and then um you know i usually start
with a little reflection who am i
who wants to know the answer what is it
that wants to know the answers to the
question who am i
what is my purpose
what do i want for me and the world
what am i grateful for that's how i
start
then i go into a little bit of breathing
and then mantra of meditation and then
what i do is i witness
what's happening on the screen of my
consciousness just becoming
aware and sooner or later you realize
that
what's happening on the screen of
consciousness is not who you are you're
the one who's
watching that and then what's happening
on the screen of your consciousness
ultimately leads to deep insights about
mind and body
and the physical world which actually
doesn't really exist
but we can get into that when we talk
about metahuman
but i think if people just ask these
four questions every day
before they start the day even without a
prolonged meditation
process who am i what do i want what's
my purpose
what am i grateful for suddenly the
windows to the bigger reality starts
to start to open absolutely this is such
a beautiful point that deepak's making
right now for everyone listening and
watching it's just
such a simple way of starting to
transcend the noise and the clutter
that we feel every morning when we wake
up and the first thing we do is look at
our phones
all you have to do is just switch that
habit for asking yourself these
questions
and you don't need to know the answers
because you know there are no fixed
answers these answers keep changing all
you have to
do is live the questions and then life
keeps moving into answers
that you need at that moment in your
life absolutely and it all happens
spontaneously synchronistically
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you
going to do to take action on it this
week when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a
91 chance of following through versus
just
35 if you got motivated but
never wrote down a plan and when you
share your plan and have public
accountability it raises your chances of
following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan to take action on it
this week let me know put it down in the
comments below
entrepreneurs are the most powerful
people in the world not just about
money not just about having strength
which it is too
but power in terms of the ability to
influence
change the ability to look at something
that we want to change
that we are not happy with in the world
and instead of just complaining about it
we want to go
and do something about it that's what
entrepreneurs do entrepreneurs are going
to solve all of the major problems of
the world because that's what we do and
if you want to tap into that power if
you want to be the game changer if you
want to solve those big problems then
you have to learn
how to be present stop getting
distracted and stop
playing small stop checking your
facebook post because you got
one extra like in the past hour that
makes you feel good
stop looking at your email and pulling
out your phone every time a new
notification comes in
these distractions are preventing you
from doing your life's work
stop playing small what am i doing right
now i'm making this video for you what
am i thinking about right now
making this video for you what do i hope
to accomplish i hope that by watching
this video
something sparks in here that helps you
play a bigger game that makes you
realize that you're getting distracted
too much
and and you're playing a smaller game
you're not doing the thing that you
should be doing that's my sincere hope
do i accomplish that
maybe if not i need to work harder i
gotta focus more i gotta get better at
what i'm doing but what i'm not doing
i'm not thinking about what am i gonna
eat for dinner tonight i'm not thinking
about
last night's game and how we won or lost
i'm not thinking about my instagram feed
and seeing if i got
a couple extra comments in the past 15
minutes because when i do that
then i'm not making a great video for
you if i'm checked out and thinking of
something else and i'm not in the task
that i'm doing right now and that means
i would be playing small
me not being present me not trying to
reach my potential
is unacceptable i'd like you to take an
audit of your day and look at
how many hours in your day is actually
being spent being
massively productive massively
productive how many hours in your day
it's not that you need to sleep less
it's just in the hours that you are
awake
you need to work harder you need to be
more productive
and that frustrates me because you have
insane talent because you have these
ideas and you have an ability and you
want to do something good and you want
to have a big impact
and you're sitting on it you're wasting
your time you're checking your facebook
and doing all these other things that
are getting in the way of you doing
something great
stop playing small so i'd like you to
make a commitment i want
you to make a commitment i want you to
say to yourself
i'm going to stop playing small and
start
being present i'm going to stop playing
small
and start being present i'm going to
stop
playing small and start being
present do that for the next 30 days and
the results will astound you
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check the link right
here below me
or if you want to know powerful ways to
become your best self check the video
right there next to me
i think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe and i'll see you there